let's go to our next point what's our
next thing we want to focus on great so
when when should have found our
formalized communication standards and
guidelines with the team in short as
soon as possible yeah it's really really
important that you set the tone very
early and be professional you know the
when you as the founder co-founders
founding team set that professionalism
it it creates you know it sort of
trickles down to the to the employees
right that you know we're not gossip is
not accepted
you know we communicate on yo via email
or if text message okay add that into it
make sure people know the channels that
they can use to communicate with you um
it's it's just it since it's incredibly
important to set that process really
really early because just like you know
you're doing co-founder alignment this
is team alignment to you need to be
aligned with your team moving forward
and always always be professional it's
so easy in these early startups to you
know you want to blow some steam off
because you're working really hard and
so you all go out and you know party and
drink together and that just doesn't it
really doesn't open up great it doesn't
set a great stage for professional
communication in the office when you do
those kinds of things yeah and a lot of
times you're starting it with two of
your friends from college or something
like that and you're not professional
because you were in a fraternity or
sorority together and you did the
opposite of being professional now
you're at an office and maybe you've
taken money from people and if you act
like you're still in your sorority or
fraternity or your you know apartment or
something like that it that's going to
trickle down and that unprofessionalism
is going to just spread and that can
lead to all kinds of bad situations
that's why I advise companies today like
mmm maybe now maybe not happy hours
maybe have lunch as a team and
de-emphasizing alcohol at the workplace
I think something that has become sort
of the standard here some people might
think something's lost but you you also
don't need to be the social life of the
party as the founder sometimes the
founders think they have to be the ones
who are throwing the party etc maybe not
maybe if your team wants to go out
that's okay but you don't have to be out
at every
so what's our next bullet point here
it's kind of funny yeah so in in that
same vein of being professional sort of
not in front of the kids so as
co-founders and founding team members
you want to specifically co-founders if
you have disagreements that's okay
you're going you're you're building this
company together you've never neither of
you have likely never done it before and
you're you're gonna have some wrinkles
but it's really important that you don't
take those disagreements on the you know
startup floor that you're taking those
behind closed doors and and you know
hashing everything out so that you can
go to the team as a united front yeah so
that they don't feel like there's some
kind of breakdown only in communication
but oh my gosh the world is ending these
co-founders are fighting all of the time
so it's it's just it's important to
maintain that professionalism and you
know having resolutions to your
conflicts not in front of your team yeah
ultimately when you know with your early
employees oftentimes they're you know
they're they're taking these risks and
making these sacrifices for you as the
founders and they are they're counting
on you and it's not necessarily always
about the you know the startup idea you
know it could be that you have recruited
people from your past that have seen you
work and want to be on your team and so
you know if that breaks down then
essentially what's left you know in a
lot of cases and some things are fine to
have a debate about you could even have
a healthy charge debate about a product
but I would say you really have to start
thinking about which topics might create
a sense of panic in the team so you've
spent all this time to build the team of
a dozen people and now you're having a
blowout fight over if you're gonna raise
money or not raise money if you're gonna
lay people off if you're gonna fire
somebody like this is the kind of stuff
that should not occur in front of team
if you want to have a structured
discussion about your go-to-market
strategy and are you going to do paid
ads or content marketing or you know how
are you going to recruit people those
are fine debates to have what I find
people sometimes do and this again goes
back to the the the first bullet point
we have fear about being professionals
they may debate something in front of
everybody that just scars them
and they just think oh now I don't have
a sense of security here if that person
can be fired on the spot I guess that
means I could be fired on the spot or if
they're arguing over if the company
should shut down you know their consumer
product and would be to be like wait a
second I bought into a mission as we
said earlier in having a Lima mission
that was the opposite way this place is
chaos and I think the fighting in front
of the kids can create chaos and then
make it hard for people to focus on work
so I think it's a very important point
what's our next one to over communicate
especially as it relates to your mission
your goals and your roles in the company
it's you want to make sure that everyone
knows what they are working towards and
the way they do that is they you over
communicate the mission you know and
just as a sort of an aside when I when I
first started at launch I was asked what
the mission was I was probably a week in
yeah and I said inspiring innovation and
supporting founders and I was told
that's the incorrect order yeah and so I
think that's really important you know I
was only a couple of days in and it was
already it rang true and it's really
important everything we do supports that
missions support founders inspire
innovation yeah and if you think about
it we came up with that from the
conference and then also investing in it
it's actually really served us because
when we look at a course like this that
we're doing here it's to support
founders yeah it might inspire some
innovation but this part is really about
supporting founders and goals are
different than missions goals are hey
this is what we want to get done this
week this month this year this quarter
the mission is something that maybe
doesn't change for the life of the
company or if it did it would be a big
discussion and those goals support that
mission right everything's going towards
that so when you're over communicating
the mission and then everybody knows
what that is
everyone's bought in then over
communicating the goals and and tracking
people which we'll get into a little bit
later but tracking people against those
goals as well and then important within
those goals is you know what your role
is you know exactly what your
responsibility is so everyone is on the
same page there's not this misalignment
and you're able to service the mission
more successfully the big problem is
sometimes you set a goal and two people
are responsible for the ball
Falls right between them you know like
like outfielders in a baseball game they
just they don't know who's actually
responsible and that's why it's very
clear to just put somebody responsible I
also like to tell people what the goals
are and then when they report in report
back on what percentage of the way you
are to hitting that goal or what goals
do you have that you don't feel you're
gonna hit and what's your strategy for
maybe changing the goal or trying
another strategy to hit that goal and
over-communicating is critical people
sending some email nobody reads email
people say things in a meeting people
are distracted if you're the manager you
have to repeat the mission and the goals
at least ten times if you want half the
people to remember it do not point
different methods of communication as
well yeah I mean email is a good place
to put it asana if you're using that or
some other track or Trello board
whatever it is but boy do you have to
repeat it and this is something that
people miss in terms of management all
the time they say well I said this and
it's like when did you say that people
are busy and distracted they've got a
million things okay our final point
seems obvious but it's obviously
important yeah so being transparent so
this you know could could it aligns with
over communicating but especially an
early stage you're early employees
likely have some kind of stock option in
your company so their stakeholders it's
really really important to to be
transparent with your employees I mean
without arguing in front of the kids
that you know what's going on within the
company what the high level you know not
only what the high level goals are but
what the high level challenges are yeah
so that everyone can be you know
focusing on solutions together yeah
instead of you know the co-founders sort
of toiling away these two things I'm not
in front of the kids and be transparent
they seem like opposites how would you
reconcile this give me a couple examples
of things that you'd say you know what
if the three of us were co-founders in
this new company we would want to take
on the side and have a discussion
privately versus things that we want to
be transparent about yeah two that go
hand-in-hand the first one that comes to
mind is so as a founder in the beginning
you know you may have issues with
payroll
making payroll and so you'll want to
discuss as a team as a co-founding team
you know what to do with we know with
that so it's either you know you have a
couple options and you know in many
cases you can either you know maybe
communicate with your employees like hey
we need to delay payroll hey we need you
to skip this payroll so so evaluating
you know the bigger picture all of that
making a decision together
and then at that point you need to
decide okay what do we communicate with
the team you know how far do we take it
so is it like hey you know this this
round specifically talking about a
shutdown kind of situation hey if you're
running out of money and you may do well
this would be very very early but yeah
and you know and that transparency would
come just you know when you're talking
to your team do you do you tell them
everything do you tell them you know hey
this investor checked and didn't come in
or you know fell through so no we can't
you know make these hires or do any of
this or do you kind of keep it close to
the chest and hope that you'll be able
to figure it out between where do you
fall on that one let's say the ground is
coming together not coming together what
would you advise I found her to do what
have you done so I this actually did
happen to me so I can tell you exactly
what we did so we we tried to be we were
transparent but we also let the team
know that we were doing everything we
possibly could to you know to basically
close the the financial gap the cash gap
that we were experiencing and gave them
essentially a timeline for what that
would look like so and give them
scenarios so you know hey if these
certain checks did come in on time this
would happen if they didn't come in on
time this would happen yeah land a and a
plan B exactly yeah and we set different
timelines so you know if if this if this
check didn't come in by and by this time
then then yeah we may need you to skip
payroll and in that case we would you
know help you and support you and
finding your next role a different
company yeah that's where really can get
dicey when the company is at the last
three months and it's a coin toss if
it's gonna work out or not you really
obligated to be candid with people
because it is their future and boy is it
terrible when people come to work one
day and there's no money left in the bag
and they just let everybody go with no
notice I am a fan of giving people
exactly and I do this with inside hey we
raised two points
million dollars we're burning 25 250 a
month and so that gives us 50 months of
runway just 75 months of runway here's
why we're investing that money every
month we could be break-even right now
but we want to invest and grow another
20 newsletters and here's the plan
and here's what we did in revenue the
last four quarters and here's what we
want to do in the next four quarters
here's how we're gonna get there so I
love being transparent about that I
understand some people maybe when you
have six to twelve months you don't want
people to be scared and running for the
door but you should be candid about it I
think in this case hey everybody last
episode I told you about this new
incredible bed called 8:00 sleep it's
called the pod and it helps you sleep
better by dynamically cooling and
heating your side of the bed or your
spouse's and then it sets a thermo alarm
so when you wake up oh boy now you can
wake up and get a little bit cooler and
raise your heart rate and make you wake
up naturally so you're super well-rested
this is a Silicon Valley back to startup
we started in New York but they've got
backwards like Khosla Ventures Y
Combinator is your capital and in
Silicon Valley you need that extra
energy you need that energy level for
you to have the right mood and the right
take-charge attitude at your startup and
be focused it's the ultimate hack in
optimizing your productivity you got to
get great sleep so I just pre-ordered
the bed and you will get the sleep you
deserve by heading to eat sleep calm
Swiss that's right good a sleep calm
slash twist and supercharge your health
and productivity and you can try the
product risk-free for 100 days they'll
take it back if you don't like it a
sleep complex twist get to sleep you
deserve by heading over to eight sleep
Tom's lash twist again it's a hundred
days you got nothing to lose and this is
gonna make you super super efficient go
ahead and enjoy the new pod from its Lee